foreign
you might think white cold cute fuzzy
huggable
or maybe you feel a bit sad imagining a
polar bear floating away on a melting
Ice Flow
either way there's a good chance that
for you polar bears are a distant
reality
but think of those living and working in
the Arctic for them melting ice doesn't
mean polar bear is floating away
it means the bear is getting stuck on
land and more desperate for food for
them polar bears can be a daily reality
and whether this reality feels safe or
scary depends on how well-prepared
people are to coexist with the world's
largest four-legged Predator after
working and living off and on with polar
bears for over 12 years I know
coexisting with them can be a challenge
and it will only get more challenging as
climate change forces our species to
increasingly overlap in the coming
decades with my organization polar bears
international I'm focused on conserving
wild polar bears while respecting and
assisting those who share their
coastlines with this carnivore
to understand how to best coexist with
polar bears we first need to understand
them and I think one of the best places
to start is with one of the most common
questions I get asked which is
how are they actually doing
it's a great question it's simple but
the answer has some nuance and can
depend on where we're looking in time
and space
if we could pause time and stop all the
impacts we're having on the planet then
sure right now the species would be okay
we still have about 25 000 Polar Bears
spread across the Arctic split into 19
different populations in Canada Russia
Norway Greenland and Alaska but
obviously we can't pause time the world
is warming and the Arctic is warming
faster than anywhere if we did nothing
to change our current path we could lose
most of the world's polar bears by the
end of the century due to habitat loss
populations are experiencing changes at
different rates depending on where they
are but ultimately all will be impacted
unless we collectively switch to clean
our Energies
so we're racing time to tackle climate
change in the long term and in the short
term trying to keep as many polar bears
in the wild as possible
but in the short term one of the biggest
hurdles these charismatic Mega fauna
face is us
polar bears use the frozen ocean for
traveling mating and hunting their main
prey Fields specifically high calorie
sealed blubber polar bears can't out
swim seals so they use the sea ice to
sneak up on unsuspecting prey polar
bears need sea ice for sustenance and
survival period
so what happens when Ice Bears start
losing their ice
they get stuck on land and they get
hungry
polar bears wants and need blubber but
they're still Bears so they will follow
their noses to fill their tummies
whatever that takes but it takes a lot
just one polar bear needs a lot of seals
and just one seal is equal to about 74
snow geese or 216 snow goose eggs it's a
big omelette or 3 million crowberries
this amount of food doesn't exist on the
tundra in quantities great enough to
sustain a population of blubber hunting
Ice Bears so when polar bears can't find
good food to eat just like people
they'll fill up on junk food and for
polar bears junk food is human food and
for a hungry bear the best late night
fast food takeout can be their Northern
neighborhood's trash
but we have a thing in conservation a
Fed bear is a dead bear and this has
major implications for coexistence
many people work and live across the
North and some indigenous cultures have
centuries-old deep knowledge of polar
bears
but as the world is warming and bears
are spending more time on land more
people are moving North and also
spending more time on the land and
bringing with them more food and more
garbage and they might not be so Bear
Aware
this is a rising safety concern for
humans who are always the number one
priority
it's also a concern for the Bears
because when a polar bear has a negative
encounter with a human it risks being
taken out of the population in a defense
kill which is the legal killing of an
animal to defend flight for property
now here I should also mention that in
parts of the range polar bears are
harvested under a quota system informed
by science and Indigenous knowledge
if I don't mention it people can think
I'm hiding it and when I do they can be
surprised that I'm not opposed
it is incredibly important that we
protect the rights of indigenous peoples
to practice their traditions and right
now that practice is not a significant
threat to the species
where we could see population level
impacts is through climate change or if
defense kills which count toward quotas
defense kills start Rising above the
relatively low quotas that's when I
worry
but people can't worry about
conservation when their lives are at
risk
so we need to help limit negative polar
bear encounters and support people in
protecting themselves with whatever
tools work best for them
and to help with that we can provide
tools that are non-lethal
luckily non-lethal tools are available
and more are being developed
particularly in Canada which is home to
two-thirds of the world's polar bears
and one of the best testing grounds for
tools is in the self-proclaimed polar
bear capital of the world Churchill
Manitoba Churchill is home to the
Western Hudson Bay population some of
the best studied and most southern polar
bears in the world
in this region the ice free season is
lengthening meaning these bears are on
land longer and have less access to
calories compared to their grandparents
this does not mean all the Bears are
starving to death
it means the females are having a harder
time having Cubs the Cubs are having a
harder time becoming adults and some
bears have just moved elsewhere in
search of better conditions
as a result this population has declined
from about 1200 bears in the 1980s to
just over 600 today almost 50 percent
Churchill is also home to about 900
people but Grows by thousands during
tourist season and visitors do sometimes
ask me
do polar bears really come into town or
is this some tourism ploy oh yeah they
come into town
so this is from last fall which is in
bear season October November in
Churchill and the local woman had gone
out through living room about 4 AM and
watched this through her window and no
doubt she called the polar bear alert
hotline right after which is a real
thing but you can tell how big they are
curious and pretty rude
yeah
so polar bears are an economic Keystone
in Churchill driving tourism and
creating jobs it's important Churchill
protects them and their people which
they do through a wide variety of
efforts but one of the most interesting
and effective is their Waste Management
unsurprisingly Churchill's garbage dump
used to be outdoors which was fine until
it became a popular polar bear Buffet
so this is a problem for the Bear's
Health but also because when they're on
their way to the snack bar they risk
bumping into people
polar bears are no more likely to
actively hunt and kill people than black
bears
but they are more likely to attack near
towns especially when food is nearby so
Churchill did the smart thing and
they've just moved their garbage dump
indoors now the Bears can't even get to
it
they also installed residential bear
resistant bins so no polar bear with
late night Munchies in this town gets
any Ron food rewards
Churchill continues to evolve their
Waste Management because it's key in
coexistence but not everywhere can do
what Churchill's done so we need more
options
polar bears international is working on
Innovative Technologies that could help
provide longer lead times between when
polar bears and people meet or prevent
them from meeting altogether just one
example GPS tracking it can tell us
where when and why polar bears move it's
critical data but we've only
successfully colored adult females adult
males have these like pylon heads with
necks thicker than their skulls and they
just pull collars right off
and then the sub-adults are still
growing and this is really too bad
because the sub-adults or the teenagers
often cause the most trouble big
surprise
so we started working with 3m the sticky
stuff company that makes Post-it notes
and they're helping us figure out how to
stick a Tracker to any bears fur these
buron fur tags could be a conservation
Game Changer letting us temporarily take
any bear that comes too close to a
community and upon relocation we can
track that bear and intercept it before
it gets too close
this could help reduce dumpster diving
and reduce negative human bear
encounters keeping both species safer we
also hope the tags could be used on
other species that maybe need some
support staying away from us humans
so there's different coexistence tools
being worked on for different needs
across the north but we can't talk about
conservation without mentioning one of
the most important tools of all
education if you are going into Bear
Country polar or otherwise please get
Bear Aware
Stay Together secure your snacks and
carry a deterrence like flares or
bangers or bear spray bear spray works
even in the cold and the wind
but finally the number one most
important co-existence tool we have
is our willingness to cut carbon
emissions and stop trapping so much heat
in our atmosphere
but on that note I have some optimism
sea ice is very responsive to
atmospheric temperatures
we can keep this habitat in the Arctic
but it will mean drastically reducing
our emissions and eventually getting
them to zero polar bears are fat white
hairy canaries in the coal mine
warning us to act now the faster we
switch to clean our energies the better
we can protect future generations of
polar bears and people
I'd be lying if I said I wasn't worried
but action is the best antidote to
anxiety and I'm working to ensure
climate change doesn't separate our
species for good but until then it's
bringing us too close together
coexistence is the only option let's
make it safe for all
thank you
[Applause]